[Música]
tem uma série da tv escola é um
documentário que eu gosto muito de
assistir que chama quando éramos peixes
e nessa série ele mostra a relação entre
a estrutura óssea dos peixes ea
estrutura óssea dos seres humanos
e ela fala que essa passagem da vida na
água pra terra nós sabemos é que foi
através dos anfíbios mais
especificamente através desse peixe
chamado titanic e quando a gente fala em
anfíbios
a gente costuma lembrar nem sempre da
água quando fala carro anfíbio é havia
uma fila o carro anfíbio aquele carro
que anda também na água
um avião anfíbio é o avião que consegue
pousar na água então eu achava que a
palavra fibra tem alguma relação com
água mas aí eu fui buscar no dicionário
e vi que anfíbio na verdade não tem
relação com a água
o fbi o off na verdade quer dizer ambos
então são animais que conseguem viver em
ambos os meios nem tanto na água quanto
na terra mas vocês viram eu fui
apresentada não vem falar de biologia
vou falar de mobilidade urbana a minha
eu lembro que que o meu interesse
mobilidade urbana começou mais ou menos
quando eu tinha uns 8 anos de idade
eu quando era criança eu dizia que
queria ser guarda de trânsito
eu gostava do trânsito daquela coisa do
trânsito e dizia que queria ser guarda
de trânsito ea família da minha mãe do
rio de janeiro e aí sempre que o rio de
janeiro eu via o metrô andava de metrô
lá no rio de janeiro ficava encantado
com o metrô no e eu dizia que queria ser
maquinista de metrô que um quando
crescer eu queria ser maquinista de
metrô é porque eu ficava encantado com
aqueles entrava num túnel aqui o metrô
levar você chegava em outro lugar ea
liberdade que aquilo dava a facilidade
que você tenha de se deslocar pela
cidade com aquilo mas não é quando eu
era criança aqui mas eu não tinha metrô
né o meu pai ele tinha um carro que era
o meio de transporte e toda a família
ele levava a minha mãe trabalho
levava e minhas irmãs para a escola para
o curso de inglês do cursinho
pré-vestibular para a natação é bom para
todo lugar era o carro da família levava
até por cursinhos pré vestibular até que
eu passei no vestibular completar 18
anos e ganhei um carro então o carro na
minha adolescência sempre foi um sonho
pra mim eu queria completar logo 18 anos
para poder ter o carro para poder ter
aquela liberdade que eu acreditava que
ia ter com o carro né e eu era tão
apaixonado por carro na adolescência
quando eu tinha 13 anos
o meu presente de aniversário foi uma
assinatura da revista quatro rodas
meus pais me interessa essa assinatura
da revista eu gostava muito de ler e me
comunicar com a revista uma nova carta
pra eles né essa interação com a revista
e quando eu tinha 14 anos eu fui estudar
mecânica na escola técnica é fascinado
mesmo por essa questão da dadá dos
transportes e mobilidade e aí não é como
eu disse meu interesse por mobilidade e
surgiu mesmo quando eu era quando era
criança eu brincava na rua fazia
verdadeira cidade na rua com um pedaço
de cerâmica eu desenhava as cidades
assim para brincar com aqueles carrinhos
hot wheels
às vezes em casa mesmo já estava várias
folhas de papel para brincar dentro de
casa fazer uma cidade de casa e e sempre
tivesse interesse pela mobilidade urbana
e aí quando eu eu fui estudar
arquitetura e urbanismo foi mais por
conta do desenho técnico que eu tinha na
escola técnica no que hoje é o ifal né
do que pelo organismo mas quando eu saí
da universidade eu saí gostando mais
bonito do que de arquitetura e aí quando
me formei estava recém formado
eu estava planejando uma viagem para são
paulo e por acaso eu conheci o blog do
thiago benicchio que o jornalista thiago
benicchio lá de são paulo que chama
apocalipse motorizado blog dele que ele
tirou esse nome do livro do apocalipse
motorizado e ele mostrava nesse blog ele
ele não alimenta mais esse blog mas ele
mostrava essa nova visão de mobilidade
que a gente tem hoje que é da cidade
focado nas pessoas não a cidade focada
no automóvel
aí eu fiquei encantado com aquilo ali
com aquela naquela nova visão de
mobilidade que que ele mostrava no blog
mas eu eu acreditava que aquilo era a
visão nova
mas na verdade não era nova né a adin
jacobs na década de 60 e 50 e 60 ela já
batalharam por isso lá nos estados
unidos nova york
ela estava muito por isso e atualmente
ela já falecido atualmente ea ong que é
um humanista dinamarquês
ele vem espalhando essa ideia pelo mundo
né desde a década de 60 também desde a
década de 70 ele espalhasse pelo mundo e
coincidentemente essa semana eu estava
aqui no brasil ele passou por são paulo
para o porto alegre dando palestras
falando o que as cidades precisam ter
para ser agradáveis para as pessoas não
para os carros
então em 2006
eu fui aprovado no concurso público e
foi trabalhar no bairro do centro em
maceió
e aí eu morava na ponta verde
e aí me deslocava para o centro de carro
todos os dias eu pegava engarrafamento
todos os dias na barão de atalaia
estudar até hoje ainda é recorrente
engarrafamento e aí eu indo um dia para
o trabalho de carro numa semana na
semana seguinte na outra semana disse
poxa eu não vou passar a minha vida né
fazendo isso todos os dias né eu não vou
agüentar isso
e aí eu vendo aquelas aquilo que o
thiago benicchio mostrava no blog dele e
as iniciativas que as pessoas tenham em
outra cidade é de usar a bicicleta como
transporte
eu resolvi experimentar para o trabalho
de bicicleta e aí eu fui num sábado não
peguei a bicicleta no sábado para
experimentar para ver se ficaria muito
cansado e se aguentaria e fui foi
tranquilo aí a partir da segunda feira
eu já resolvi ir de bicicleta do
trabalho e aí né
lá no trabalho nem eu quando ia de carro
ainda tem que ficar procurando vaga para
estacionar o carro né ai de bicicleta já
não tinha mais esse problema eu tinha um
espaço para guardar a bicicleta no
trabalho amarrada num pequeno porte la
no trabalho e sempre ficava escutando os
meus colegas reclamando que não
conseguiram vaga para estacionar o carro
que tiver dificuldade que ficaram
engarrafamento e diziam que me viram
passar no engarrafamento e estavam na
varanda além daquele engarrafamento e me
viram passar de bicicleta e eu sempre
chegava no horário não me atrasava não
tinha problema nenhum
levava uma mochila com roupas toalhas
sabonetes e tudo e tomava banho no
trabalho já trabalhava até mais mas
agradável e ele sempre me contava ensaio
você passando no trânsito detran do
trabalho
e aí já faz dez anos que eu venho
fazendo isso só que hoje não trabalha
mais no centro eu trabalho na fernandes
lima na no bairro do farol
e aí eu tenho que enfrentar a
agressividade dos motoristas de ônibus e
dos motores de táxi na faixa azul é que
a bicicleta foi recomendado que ela
utilizasse a faixa azul e tenha se esse
conflito na faixa azul
mas aí usando cada vez mais a bicicleta
e cada vez menos o carro né eu eu eu
percebi que quando eu estava de carro eu
ficava impaciente quando todo mundo
trânsito com o carro a vontade que eu
tenho que fazer como michael douglas no
filme um dia de fúria né é guardar o
carro e sair do carro deixar o carro no
engarrafamento embora do carro porque
aquilo ali é como se fosse um trambolho
que você carrega com você e você não tem
saída acertada em um casamento com o
carro você tá preso na garagem sendo tem
que fazer se não tem liberdade com
aquilo e como guilherme jordão falou no
ted recife é como a cascata do caracol
na que o cacau tem que carregar aquilo
para todo lugar né
e aí usando cada vez menos o carro e
cada vez mais a bicicleta no ano passado
em 2015 eu deus meu carro no último
carro ea completar cinco anos
e aí nós já começa a ficar obsoletos e
já começa a ter problema no carro já
está na época de trocar e eu estava
pensando em trocar meu carro
aí eu pensei poxa eu estou usando tão
pouco o carro estava usando o carro uma
vez por semana uma vez a cada 15 dias o
carro está parado na garagem que ficava
lá como objeto de decoração na garagem
aí eu conheci site meu carro é um
monstro nesse site ele calcula ele faz o
cálculo de você coloca o valor do carro
valor que você paga o ipva de
combustível de tudo de imposto de de
tudo e ele calcula quanto o seu carro
custa pra você eu fiz o cálculo do meu
carro e disse que ele me custava mil
reais por mês
hoje eu vou pagar mil reais por mês na
ele já tenha custado 80 mil reais eu vou
pagar mil reais por mês para um carro
para ficar parado na garagem né então se
eu não estou usando o carro eu posso
pegar seis mil reais e usar de outra
forma então eu decidi vender o carro né
então se nós pensarmos é que o salário
mínimo do brasil é de 880 reais
atualmente e que o meu carro estava
custando mil reais
então a gente já começa a ver que esse
transporte é acessível a todos que nem
todas as pessoas têm
reais pra manter um carro e se não é
acessível a todos é um transporte
excludente mas não é um transporte para
todo mundo então mesmo que todo mundo
tivesse condições de ter o carro mesmo
que todas as pessoas tivessem condições
de ter mil reais tem um carro está todo
mundo na cidade pudesse deslocar de
carro não haver espaço na cidade por um
simples motivo é porque o carro ele
ocupa muito espaço da cidade
então é isso que provoca essa expansão
horizontal da cidade que se dá tempo
está sempre expandindo para poder
abrigar mais carros na cidade
e aí vão criando bairros nova a gente vê
agora a prefeitura com essa intenção de
expandir a cidade do litoral norte então
sempre expandindo a cidade
horizontalmente com as distâncias
ficando cada vez maiores ea gente vê que
as cidades maiores como são paulo por
exemplo que tem um tamanho imenso na
tela cheia de viadutos e nova cidade e
mesmo assim tem seus congestionamento em
uma escala diferente a gente está
seguindo o mesmo caminho
então de bicicleta é esse aqui o
aplicativo escrava que é um aplicativo
pra você marcar seus percursos de
corrida ou de bicicleta e quando eu saí
de casa olívia esse aplicativo no
celular e ele registra todos os
percursos que eu faço na cidade através
de gps
então essas linhas azuis são as linhas
que eu por onde circulam em maceió
então vocês podem ver que o o oro por
aqui né nunca mais lhe falando aqui e aí
num raio de seis quilômetros é tudo
aquilo que eu posso fazer de bicicleta é
tudo aquilo que eu faço de bicicleta na
cidade então a minha cidade é uma cidade
mais compacta é a sociedade que o
alcance de bicicleta uma cidade num raio
de seis quilômetros
aí a gente pensa poxa mas é limitado
esse raio de seis quilômetros na europa
a cidade é maior do que isso
mas se a gente for pensar no carro o
carro ele também tem a sua limitação
eu posso por exemplo morar em paripueira
ou em marechal deodoro que são cidades
vizinhas aqui de maceió e vi todos os
dias morar e trabalhar aqui em maceió dá
uma distância de 30 quilômetros mais ou
menos então essa limitação do carro
cerca de 30 quilômetros na que o raio de
alcance do carro pra você fazer uma
distância que de meia hora uma hora né
mas de bicicleta 6 km eu faço
tranquilamente e 20 minutos
então o o oab a bicicleta ela promove
uma cidade mais compacta é isso que os
manos urbanistas falam que é a cidade de
bicicleta é a cidade do transporte
coletivo na cidade mais compacta nessa
cidade respondeu horizontalmente
então é é usando cada vez menos o carro
nem sem aquela aqueles mil reais que
estava gastando com o carro eu agora eu
percebi que eu tenho mais liberdade para
me deslocar na cidade do que quando eu
tinha carro
eu acreditava que o carro ele me daria
liberta quando tinha 18 anos acreditava
que ele me daria liberdade para me
deslocar pela cidade mas hoje com com
todos esses aplicativos que nós temos
não é pra celular pra relacionados à
mobilidade e já me conhecer e 99
tatibitate acção para trás o hub que
chegou recentemente em maceió que é
muito polêmico e ainda é sempre
necessário que eles chegam que ele chega
e tem também os aplicativos de
bicicletas de aluguel que tem o exemplo
do velib de paris o city bike queda de
nova york o bike samba de são paulo
recife também tem seus suas bicicletas
de aluguel que são por aplicativos de
celular e mas ainda não têm bicicletas
de aluguel tem o globo a quebra quando
você quer viajar de uma cidade para a
outra você faz carona com seus amigos
têm os carros compartilhados que esses
açúcar e joe k tem outras empresas
também fazem isso que você não precisa
ter o carro carro o que se pensa hoje do
carro é o carro com a posse você ter o
carro é você usar o carro é como um
serviço
você usa quando você precisa se eu
preciso do carro uma vez por semana ela
usa uma vez por semana não se tem um
carro parado na garagem durante a semana
toda outras pessoas podem usar esse
carro compartilhado e tem também as
locadoras de carro que já são
tradicionais que a gente já conhece
nessa questão de estado a sair em
aplicativos também que mostra o percurso
dos ônibus então o que eu queria a
mensagem que eu queria passar para vocês
é que essa cidade que nós construímos
agora a partir do ao longo do século 20
nessa cidade focada no automóvel é uma
cidade que nós escolhemos que ela fosse
assim a cidade foi imposta a ela foi
imposta pela indústria automobilística
para que nós vivenciamos necessidade ela
nos fez acreditar que essa é a melhor
forma de viver
então nós passamos por um período longo
de ditadura aqui no brasil nós agora não
estamos mais na ditadura nós vivemos uma
democracia mas o poder da mídia ainda é
muito forte nesse programa propaganda na
televisão é sempre estão mostrando é o
carro como um sinônimo de status como
sinônimo de poder que você precisa ter o
carro para se tornar livre para ser uma
pessoa mais bonita você tem que ter o
seu carro e aí nós construímos cidades
excludentes na cidade onde os pedestres
ficam espremidos nas calçadas onde
todo o espaço da cidade é oferecido para
os carros na a as gestões municipais
gastam fortunas de dinheiro dinheiro
público para fazer obras para caber mais
carros e aí logo depois que essas obras
são feitas mais carros em circulação e
as obras se tornam né ineficazes mas nós
temos né soluções exitosas que foram
adotadas em várias cidades mundo afora
aquele a urbanista que mostrei ele
trabalhou em nova york em um exemplo de
nova iorque dividiu né as suas avenidas
com espaço para bicicleta espaço pra
faixas exclusivas para ônibus calçadas
acessíveis e os pedais poder encaminhar
com com mais facilidade e espaços
adequados pra cá o pds esse exemplo de
cima de helsinque por desculpa dada
muito ânimo e com espaços agradáveis
pessoas circularem não mexemos em maceió
ao centro da cidade que tem um calçadão
no centro é um exemplo desse espaço não
é que as pessoas os carros não entram só
espaço que só as pessoas podem circular
é como se fosse um shopping center é o
céu a céu aberto o shopping center fez
foi colocar ar condicionado enclausurar
as pessoas naquilo que já se via como
benefícios das ruas de pedestres
então a mensagem que eu queria passar
para vocês é essa é que quando eu
comecei a falar que eu pedi que nós
sejamos a fibras é que nós não
precisamos ser apenas motoristas nem
apenas ciclistas nem apenas pedestres
nem apenas usuário de ônibus
nós podemos sim os filhos os filhos como
eu mostrei são eles são animais que
vivem em diversos meios né que conseguem
ser detalhes vários meios
então eu acredito que a partir do
momento que nós conseguimos deixar um
pouco o carro em casa usar um pouco a
bicicleta um pouco o transporte coletivo
caminhar um pouco pela cidade né a
partir do momento que nós nos tornamos
livres e e de conseguir viver tanto
dentro do carro como fora do carro
vai ser um grande passo evolutivo para
que a a gente consiga ter cidades mais
agradável de se viver nas cidades que
não sejam apenas na cidade para os
carros como a gente tem hoje mais
cidades voltadas para as pessoas
[Aplausos]